put up your sword
the enemy is still out there
the question now is
[Music]
where hi musabida from geek culture in
singapore i hope you're doing well i'm
very well nice sofa
oh thank you it's super bright
little briggs is coming out really soon
can you talk about the immense pleasure
and pressure of creating you know a new
take on this iconic franchise
yeah there is a huge amount of pressure
um and that's because it's so beloved
and so i keep having to remind myself
that like that's lovely to be in
something that people are so passionate
about and have loved for so long um yeah
it's a real gift um but yeah you get
moments where you think
how is this happening i can't do this
and then
you just have to allow them because i
think that's
that's sanity really you can't think
this is normal
now speaking of something that's beloved
you are galadriel like the color drill
so what was it like when you first found
out that you won the role and how did
you prepare for it
um yeah when i first found out that i
was gonna be in this show um it was just
before a screening of a film i was in
and i thought i was dealing with it
quite well and then during the q a i
just thought about the fact that i was
going to new zealand just passed out
um
and since then
i've been kind of slowly accepting that
this is what it is a lot of pinch me
moments um and to prepare for it a huge
part of it was
um the physical aspect of being an elk
so we had an amazing movement director
who we kind of spoke about like how de
elves here how do lc
um how do they move through the world um
and then
amazing stunt quarters and coordinators
and
a wonderful dialect coach because for me
a big part of tolkien's world is
language
and
i was really interested the fact that
glad drill is bilingual as i am um so
exploring that was
a big pathway to her
it seems like el adrial will change the
course of many people's lives moving
forward starting with hellbrand but in
return how did they
shape her and in her journey trying to
find sauron
um so i think there is an element of
arrogance to the elves and i think she
will learn humility
um as she goes through um
and yeah she's gonna meet lots of people
and she's gonna get her ring which will
be really exciting
now there was one particular scene that
i loved and it was the one of her and
the seas she was swimming away from this
how is that like how was filming that
light because it was insane i was like
that is crazy
yeah um it was so much fun filming that
because when we were on this huge water
tank
um with this raft in the middle when
this was about 10 of us on the raft
um and you can't get on and off in
between takes so we all just got to know
each other
really
well yeah
and then filming the
that scene
um
was quite funny because we had the
director on the microphone
um basically trying to frighten us with
where his monster was coming from and
things so it was really good fun and no
one fell in which i was surprised we all
managed to stay on deck
that is impressive that's great i'm
really excited for fans to see that
now i just want to know what is your
best memory of filming throughout this
entire series
[Music]
it's difficult to pick one but um i
worked with a wonderful woman called
morgan
who was um
a driver on the show and also kind of
was on set as uh
an ad
and we
she joined in in all of my training and
just every morning driving into work
with her and we had a little playlist
we'd sing along songs together and it
was really kind of
the friendships i made of which she was
a really important one those are my best
memories
what song though and i'm curious what's
on the playlist i'm curious
you need some 80s like power balance to
get you through the day
[Music]
you